deschamps
mais bon
c'est vraiment une philosophique 4,5
avec ma soeur cette fête à tous à tous
les deux puis je pense avec les embiez
fait le deuil ma carrière sportive qui
est de type de ce rose à l'épée qui est
un rêve que je fais samuel n'a pas mis
de temps à réaliser son rêve
à 21 ans non seulement il va participer
à ses premiers jeux il fait déjà partie
des favoris
son ascension était rapide avec ses
résultats il devient un des leaders de
l'équipe canadienne du canada l'orgueil
de faire la révolution
en début de saison 2016 2017 il connaît
du succès un peu demande deux médailles
d'or et une d'argent en quatre courses
de son propre aveu il était devenu un
petit peu trop confiant
pour les cours suivants en asie il
réalise des performances en deçà de ses
capacités il s'est soumis à un exercice
d'introspection et j'avais perdu un peu
l'aspect de la course 2 peu importe le
pays peu importe à passenans qui est là
il peut de base il est l'hôte à cause de
toi de peau perd ses petites affaires
qui tu allumes comme ça donc je les
retrouver assez rapidement mais c'est
vraiment de comprendre pourquoi il avait
perdu puis de leur amener une touche ma
cellule a vite retrouvé le chemin du
podium
il a remporté la médaille d'argent du
1500 m des championnats du monde
bien sûr mais bon
vous avez évoqué
richir
si samuel arrive à être aussi efficaces
c'est qu'il a trouvé un équilibre entre
la ville et l'entraînement et son besoin
d'évasion
lui qui est originaire de ferland et
boileau au saguenay un village d'à peine
600 habitants pour moi la forêt ça
représente beaucoup ça va prendre
c'est mon point d'ancrage un peu ça me
permet de me libérer l'esprit peut
changer d'air
je reviens la semaine je fais ma semaine
ça serait plus facile pour moi ça c'est
la liberté puisse peut pas emmener sa
marie josée turcotte radio canada
montréal